mauvaise nouvelle pour les
professionnels du disque la france
épargnée jusque-là subit à son tour une
chute des ventes de disques - 13% depuis
le début de l'année principale
explication les piranhas gelé piratage
sur internet qui ne cesse de progresser
ils ont doublé en un an mais les grandes
compagnies ont décidé de s'organiser
pour les contrer anne charline lambard
lots liés oui coëx le dernier album de
david bowie le dvd de matrix 3 benjamin
fait ses courses il ne compte pas se
sert à volonté les cd qu'ils repèrent à
20 euros dans les magasins sont sur
internet gratuites les dernières sorties
les tractions les sites de vente en
ligne un simple copier coller de
l'artiste et de l'album vers les sites
pirates et le tour est joué
c'est vraiment pratiquement naturel
quand vous êtes sur un ordinateur
connecté à internet de télécharger des
fichiers très facilement donc
donc vous n'avez pas le sentiment fait
d'être un maître
30 kg a raté quelque chose ou une oeuvre
ou ou un artiste par exemple tous les
jours 5 millions de chansons
huit cent mille films s'échange dans le
monde le piratage est un secret de
polichinelle
le mode d'emploi est même donnée dans
les magasins se connaître un petit peu
au franchement c'est très simple
pour télécharger
de petits logiciels de nulle part et
c'est pas trop la gamme et voilà déjà
chez gucci mais violent qui pensent les
copies omniprésente
emi music france veut leur donner une
proportion normale sur le marché pour
cette médor l'attitude de certains
clients les désole vous allez le samedi
matin à la fnac vous le savez la famille
à la fnac ou megastore n'importe où la
semaine question de magasin et vous
allez entendre dix fois dans l'après
midi
non c'est pas le cdg de le copier ça
rend fou ça me rend hystérique dans sa
guerre contre les pirates
la compagnie mise sur le téléchargement
payant est donc légale pour se protéger
elle a mis en place un logiciel pour
empêcher la copie de ces cds le copy
control problème
le système est jugée inefficace pire ils
pénalisent certains consommateurs
les cds ne peuvent être lus dans
certains lecteurs dans cette guerre
universal préfère attendre le temps
d'affûter ses armes contre les pirates